>> Sandra: ALL RIGHT.
MEANWHILE A LOT OF LOOMING
QUESTIONS OVER WHAT HAPPENS
NEXT AS FAR AS STIMULUS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE STRUGGLING
DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
YOU HAVE THE DOW UP 315 POINTS
ON TWO THINGS, HOPE OVER A
CORONAVIRUS VACCINE AND THAT
CONGRESS WILL GET TOGETHER AND
GET SOMETHING DONE.
LARRY KUDLOW CAN GIVE US AN
UPDATE.
THE WHITE HOUSE ECONOMIC
ADVISOR.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US THIS
MORNING?
THERE SEEMS TO BE OPTIMISM ON
WALL STREET.
IS SOMETHING GETTING DONE?
>> WELL LOOK, I THINK -- I
AGREE WITH THE VACCINE ALTHOUGH
WE CAN’T NECESSARILY VERIFY
RUSSIA AS REAGAN USED TO SAY.
TRUST BY VERIFY.
I WOULD ADD THE PRESIDENT’S
PRESSER SATURDAY NIGHT WHERE HE
ANNOUNCED THE EXECUTIVE ORDERS
REALLY HELPED THE MARKET ROAR
YESTERDAY.
IT WAS UP OVER 350 POINTS.
I THINK THAT’S CONTINUING TODAY.
WE HAVE HAD ALSO GOOD NUMBERS
ON JOBS.
JUST GREAT NUMBERS ON THE JOBS
REPORT LAST FRIDAY BUT EVEN
MORE GOOD NUMBERS YESTERDAY AND
THIS MORNING NFIB, SMALL
BUSINESS CONFIDENCE WAS DOWN A
TAD BUT STILL HOLDING A HIGH
LEVEL.
THE ECONOMY LOOKS GOOD.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN
A LOT OF IMPORTANT ASSISTANCE
TO THE UNEMPLOYED AND
PRO-GROWTH MEASURES FOR THOSE
WHO ARE WORKING AND THOSE WHO
WANT TO GO BACK TO WORK.
I THINK THAT’S HELPING THE
STORY.
>> Sandra: ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
THE BEST OPTION, LARRY?
FOX NEWS IS REPORTING THIS
MORNING AND HAD CHAD PERGRAM ON
REPORTING THERE HAS BEEN NO
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN THE WHITE
HOUSE AND CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS
SINCE THE DISCUSSION CEASED
FRIDAY AFTERNOON.
CAN YOU TELL US IF ANYTHING HAS
CHANGED ON THAT FRONT?
>> WHAT I CAN SAY IS AS THE
PRESIDENT SAID YESTERDAY AS
SECRETARY MNUCHIN SAID, WE’RE
WILLING TO NEGOTIATE.
WE ARE WILLING TO SIT DOWN AS
LONG AS IT’S A SERIOUS
NEGOTIATION.
THUS FAR IT HAS NOT BEEN
SERIOUS.
THE NUMBERS -- DEMOCRATIC
NUMBERS ARE WAY TOO HIGH.
WE AREN’T GOING TO JUST SPLIT
THE DIFFERENCE.
MEANWHILE IF YOU LOOK AT THEIR
PLAN, SANDRA, A THIRD OF IT HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH COVID, OKAY?
IT HAS TO DO WITH MILE --
NOTHING TO DO WITH COVID.
THAT’S A DEMOCRAT WISH LIST.
TAKE THAT OUT.
CHOP THE NUMBER DOWN.
THERE IS STUFF WE WOULD LIKE.
WE WOULD LOVE TO EXTEND THE
PAYROLL PROTECTION FOR SMALL
BUSINESS.
WE WANT VERY MUCH TO BE ABLE TO
PUT ADDITIONAL MONEY IN FOR
SAFE AND SECURE SCHOOL OPENINGS.
THE PRESIDENT IS STILL OPEN TO
DIRECT MAILING OF CHECKS OF
$1200 PER PERSON.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WE COULD
TALK ABOUT, MORE THAN WILLING
TO.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO
CHANGE THEIR VIEWS AND THEY’VE
GOT TO BE -- SHOW US IT’S A
SERIOUS MATTER.
>> Sandra: OKAY.
MCCONNELL IS SAYING THE
DEMOCRATS BLOCKED THIS
CORONAVIRUS LEGISLATION.
HE SAYS THE PRESS IS COVERING
IT LIKE ANOTHER ROUTINE
POLITICAL STAND-OFF.
I’LL GET YOUR DESCRIPTION OF
THIS MOMENT IN A SECOND.
FIRST HERE IS CHUCK SCHUMER
REACTING TO THE EXECUTIVE
ACTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S EXECUTIVE
ORDER ON UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS
IS PUT TOGETHER IN SUCH A
SLOPPY WAY THAT IT WILL TAKE
WEEKS OR MONTHS FOR STATES TO
EVEN IMPLEMENT.
MILLIONS COULD LOSE EVERYTHING
BEFORE THEY EVER SEE A CHECK.
REPUBLICANS MUST GET BACK TO
THE NEGOTIATING TABLE.
RESPOND TO THAT, LARRY.
AND UNDER THIS PLAN LAID OUT BY
THE PRESIDENT, WHEN WOULD
AMERICANS SEE THAT CHECK?
>> TWO POINTS.
FIRST OF ALL, WE PUT UP -- GOP,
SENATOR MCCONNELL PUT UP SHORT
TERM EXTENSIONS OF UNEMPLOYMENT
AND DEMOCRATS BLOCKED IT AT
LEAST TWICE.
IT IS SILLY TO SAY IT WILL TAKE
A LONG TIME.
THEY COULD HAVE GOTTEN THAT
DONE A WEEK OR 10 DAYS AGO.
THE STATES ARE IN POSITION TO
INCREASE THE UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS.
THE $600 PLUS THAT CAME OUT IN
MARCH WAS ADMINISTERED BY THE
STATES WITH THE HELP OF THE
LABOR DEPARTMENT.
THE LABOR DEPARTMENT HAS PUT
OUT A NUMBER OF CIRCULARS
ALREADY SAYING THEY WILL GO AND
HELP THE STATES IN ANY WAY
POSSIBLE.
THIS IS NOT THAT HARD.
WE PUT OUT A FORMULA.
LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT.
SOME PEOPLE ON SUNDAY WEREN’T
LISTENING TO WHAT WE SAID OR
WHATEVER.
THE STATES FIRST OF ALL IF THEY
GIVE $100 ALREADY IN BENEFITS,
JUST $100.
ANY STATE GIVES $100 THEY WILL
QUALIFY FOR THE $300 FEDERAL
PLUS UP.
THE STATES WILL DO IT.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL PUT
A $300.
>> Sandra: THE STATES WILL DO
IT.
HAVE YOU CANVASSED THOSE STATES
TO MAKE SURE THEY CAN AFFORD IT
AND ARE WILLING TO.
>> WE MODIFIED SLIGHTLY THE
MECHANICS OF THE DEAL SO
INITIALLY -- STATES CAN STILL
IF THEY PUT ANOTHER $100 IN TO
RAISE THE BENEFIT MORE
GENEROUSLY THAT’S FINE.
IT’S UP TO THEM.
ANY STATE WHO PUT IN $100
BEFORE FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS, AND EVERY STATE DID.
THEY WILL QUALIFY FOR THE EXTRA
$300.
SO THE BASELINE OF UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS FROM STATES IS ROUGHLY
$400, OKAY, PER PERSON PER WEEK.
THAT’S THE MEDIAN.
ON TOP OF THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO PUT IN
$300, SO THAT WILL GIVE THE
BENEFIT OVERALL OF $700.
THAT’S A TREMENDOUS -- THERE
ARE 16 MILLION PEOPLE
UNEMPLOYED.
THEY NEED HELP.
THEY NEED ASSISTANCE AND WE
STAND TO GIVE IT TO THEM.
>> Sandra: I THINK THE QUESTION
IS CAN THEY AFFORD IT AND
WILLING TO DO IT?
>> I’M SAYING THEY’VE ALREADY
DONE IT, SANDRA.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY’VE ALREADY
HAD THE BENEFIT PROGRAM.
>> Sandra: THIS IS GOVERNOR
CUOMO FROM NEW YORK AND THE
ARKANSAS GOVERNOR HUTCHESON PUT
OUT THE STATEMENT SAYING WE
APPRECIATE THE WHITE HOUSE
PROPOSALS TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES, HOWEVER WE’RE
CONCERNED BY THE SIGNIFICANT
COSTS THE LATEST ACTION WOULD
PLACE ON THE STATES.
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS AND
REACT TO THAT STATEMENT.
>> BOTH OF THEM ARE FRIENDS OF
MINE.
WE’LL WORK WITH THEM IF THERE
ARE ANY COMPLICATIONS.
THEIR STATES ARE FINE.
THEY’VE ALREADY CHANGED THEIR
PROGRAM TO MEET THE CARES
DEMAND OR THE CARES GENEROSITY
FROM LAST MARCH.
THEY’RE ALREADY ON THEIR WAY.
WE SOMETIME IT WILL TAKE TWO
WEEKS TO GET THE CHECKS OUT.
THE BENEFITS OUT.
IT WILL BE ADMINISTERED BY
STATES.
IT WILL BE $700 PER PERSON PER
WEEK.
THAT’S A VERY BIG NUMBER.
SECOND, LET’S NOT FORGET
PRESIDENT’S PAYROLL TAX
DEFERRAL WHICH WILL BE A WAGE
HIKE FOR MIDDLE CLASS
AMERICANS, A WAGE HIKE OF
ROUGHLY $1100 TO THE 140
MILLION PEOPLE WHO ARE HEROES.
THEY’VE BEEN ABLE TO WORK AND
THEY HAVE WHO ARE HELPING.
THE 16 MILLION UNEMPLOYED WE’RE
HELPING THE 140 MILLION WHO ARE
WORKING.
WE WANT TO PROVIDE MORE
INCENTIVES TO WORK AND COME
BACK TO WORK AND FOR THOSE WHO
ARE NOT EMPLOYED IF THEY LOOK
AT THESE NUMBERS $1100 PAY HIKE
IS AN INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO
COME BACK TO WORK.
THESE ARE CRUCIAL ITEMS TO
ASSIST, TO HELP, THE GROW TO
ECONOMY AND I THINK THAT’S A
BIG REASON -- THESE ARE BIG
REASONS WHY THE STOCK MARKET IS
FEELING SO DARN GOOD.
>> Sandra: IT IS UP 300 POINTS
THIS MORNING.
THE DOW TOPPING 28,000 FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE FEBRUARY.
WE’RE WATCHING THAT.
YOU HAVE A BUSY DAY OF MEETINGS